Jupiter is a massive terrifying planet
and despite being studied for centuries
and even visited by nine space probes in
the last 50 years the Undisputed King of
the solar system has managed to keep
some things hidden from us
until now
from planetary cannibalism to the giant
spots you've never seen before we're
going to uncover all of Jupiter's dark
secrets
okay you've most definitely heard of
Jupiter's Great Red Spot you know the
gigantic storm that's been raging for
hundreds of years yeah it's freakishly
big like wider than Earth kind of big
if Earth had a storm like that rampaging
on its surface well there would be no
more Earth as you know it
but what you might not have heard of is
that there's a new massive storm in town
it's called the Great cold spot and this
one is weird
for one it's almost as large as the
Great Red Spot it's also the coldest
place in Jupiter's clouds
about 200 degrees Celsius cooler than
its surroundings which is how it got its
name
so how did we miss this gargantuan
hurricane
well I think we've just been mesmerized
by the swirling clouds of the gas giant
and didn't look closely enough at
Jupiter's poles
and that's exactly where the great cold
spot has been hiding
but that's just what I think
scientists have a cooler explanation
the real reason why it's not easy to
observe the great cold spot is because
it's hiding behind Jupiter's powerful
auroras
yeah the same kind of phenomenon as
Earth's Northern Lights only many many
times more powerful on top of that
unlike the Great Red Spot which is not
eager to change much the great cold spot
is volatile it's constantly growing
bigger and smaller and bigger changing
its shape in a matter of weeks even days
try to keep up with that and scientists
still don't fully understand how it
formed I mean we know that the Great Red
Spot is powered by Jupiter's swirling
gases but the great cold spot could be
fueled by auroras
and Jupiter's auroras would be a
remarkable sight to see they aren't
exactly like the ones on Earth
we get our space light shows thanks to
the sun's solar wind but Jupiter's
auroras don't rely much on the Sun
they appear thanks to the charged
particles inside Jupiter's unimaginably
huge magnetosphere most of these
particles come from Jupiter's volcanic
moon IO
if the great cold spot is really formed
by auroras then it might be thousands of
years old
way older than the Great Red Spot
and it's not the only mysterious spot
lurking in Jupiter's deadly atmosphere
among the gas giants beautiful swirling
gases there lies a dark Vortex with an
intriguing name
the great Abyss
this is one of the most baffling
features scientists discovered on
Jupiter and let me remind you we've sent
nine probes to this giant
from Pioneer 10 the first spacecraft to
fly by Jupiter in 1973 to Juno the most
recent space probe to do an in-depth
study of the planet
it took Juno 20 passes to finally notice
and capture this dark center of the
great Abyss
and yet scientists don't know exactly
what this pitch black hole is or how it
formed
I would call it Jupiter's Great black
hole but I guess that name would be a
little bit confusing
besides the great Abyss isn't anything
like a black hole it's the very dark
center of a vortex
might run deep but at least it wouldn't
suck you in like a black hole would
likely not
Jupiter's atmosphere is horrifying the
gas giant is mainly made of hydrogen and
helium but its clouds are a lot more
dangerous than that
on the top it's all ammonia ice and as
soon as you dive deeper under the
colorful patterns you'd likely encounter
ammonium hydrosulfide crystals
and at the very deep depth of the gas
giant there's water ice and Vapor yeah
that's right Jupiter doesn't have a
solid surface and it's freaky
Jupiter is basically a frigid cold Cloud
floating in space with a large hydrogen
ocean at its Center yet it's the biggest
planet in the solar system
more massive than all other planets
combined
then there are winds
Jupiter's winds are ridiculously scary
they're strong enough to blow more than
three Earth's worth of material around
the planet
at the equator they go as fast as 540
kilometers per second and deep into
Jupiter's atmosphere these winds might
be blowing Jupiter's magnetic field off
Jupiter's magnetosphere is gigantic it's
21 times the diameter of Jupiter itself
no other planet in the solar system can
boast a stronger magnetosphere than
Jupiter's and as if that's not enough
this gas giant has not two but three
magnetic poles one at the North Pole
another one at the South Pole and the
third one lies near Jupiter's equator it
was just recently discovered by Juno and
was dubbed the great blue spot
I mean is it just me or could Jupiter's
spot names use a little variation
[Music]
scientists have noticed how the gas
Giant's magnetic field changes over time
and now they think the intense winds
might be causing these changes
well that's just mind-blowing but you
know what's even more stunning than that
it turns out Jupiter is a planetary
cannibal
in the early days of our solar system
the gas giant was one of the first
planets to form
it really explains why it's so gigantic
but despite being so gassy Jupiter has a
lot of heavy elements inside it and
thanks to Juno we now know that this
monstrous planet has about 30 Earth's
worth of heavy elements in it all
because Jupiter is literally gobbling up
other planets
okay they're not exactly planets more
like planetesimals these are clumps of
dust and rock that can be hundreds of
kilometers across
if Jupiter hadn't eaten them for
breakfast well these clumps could have
become a new planet like Mars or Earth
just imagine what having another rocky
planet in the solar system would be like
well sure it could have pushed Earth out
of the habitable zone or this new planet
could have crashed into Earth leaving us
without any chance to thrive here
but it could also be pretty cool if
there was another Earth-like World
nearby
I wouldn't mind another planet like
Kepler-22b wandering around the solar
system
well put on your spacesuit and jump into
the spaceship because that's a story
for another
what if
thank you